This is the Shark Tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-Lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks in hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
(all)
♪ "Sunday night slow jams" ♪
The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark to invest
the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
I'm here seeking $1 million
for 5% of my company.
Not impressed.
If the sharks hear
a great idea...
that is so cool.
They're ready to invest,
using their own money.
This is radioactive waste
out there. It sucks.
And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
Are you making an offer?
Yes. $100,000 for 30%.
I want to be in this business.
Wait a minute.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
♪♪
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner,
the queen of QVC,
holds over a hundred patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over
a half a billion dollars
in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the Nba's Dallas mavericks.
♪♪
First into the tank
is a radio deejay
from San Diego, California,
who's pitching the sharks
his syndicated radio show.
Hi, sharks.
My name is R Dub.
I'm the creator and host
of "Sunday night slow Jams."
I'm seeking $75,000
in exchange for 10% equity.
"Sunday night slow Jams"
is a love songs
And dedications show
heard across America
and around the world
on over 60 radio stations.
We feature the ultimate mix
of love songs from today
and the classics
from back in the day,
but most importantly,
special coast-To-Coast
listener dedications
that we call
"Oral Expressions."
Ooh!
"Oral ex--
Oral expressions."
Okay.
(Lori laughs)
Let me show you
how it works.
All right, sharks, so picture
this. It's Sunday night,
and we are live
from coast to coast,
hundreds of thousands
of dedicated
"Sunday night slow Jams"
Listeners
are passionately glued
to their radio,
including Mark,
who's slow-Jammin' in Dallas.
Now Mark sends a long-Distance
oral expression
across the miles to Lori...
(laughs)
Who's slow-Jammin'
in chicago.
Ooh, you go!
(laughing continues)
(blows kiss)
Mark dedicates this next
song to you, Lori.
Here's Brian Mcknight.
Oh!
(Robert) Oh! (laughs)
(Lori laughs)
Here's Brian Mcknight!
♪ Lori's the queen of QVC ♪
(laughter)
♪ You can take it to the bank ♪
♪ but Mark's the fiercest
shark in the tank ♪
that's right.
Brian isn't only one of
the most requested artists
on "Sunday night Slow jams,"
but he's also a fan
of the show himself.
Sharks, listen, there's
no greater feeling than love,
and every Sunday night,
people all over the world
fall in Love
all over again because of
the "Sunday night slow jams."
♪ It's the the "Sunday night
slow Jams" ♪
♪ Everybody, it's the "Sunday
night slow jams" ♪
It's True.
"Sunday night slow Jams" Has
amazing ratings in every city.
But I need your help
to grow the show
and get it on in every Market
across America.
Look, more radio stations
mean more money.
So, sharks, tell me,
who's ready to slow jam?
♪ It's "The Sunday night
slow Jams" ♪
♪ Help me sing it, it's the ♪
(with Brian)
♪ "Sunday night slow Jams" ♪
(Robert) Whoo!
(laughter)
Brian Mcknight, yeah!
(Brian) I'm here all week.
Mcknight, baby! Yeah!
Thank you all.
Thank you. Thank you.
Whoo!
Brian, what's your
connection to everything?
Uh, we're friends, and...
Oh, just friends?
Okay.
And he is
one of the leading deejays
that play the music
that I create.
So... syndicated radio
is a horrible business.
Wow. Where is the love?
What makes your show better,
makes it stand out, profitable,
gives it an opportunity
for an investor
to make his money back?
Well, "Sunday night slow Jams"
Is already making money.
This year, we're gonna earn
$350,000.
That's revenue, right?
In ad sales, correct.
So how exactly does radio
syndication work as a business?
I'm not very familiar
with that.
Let me try to explain it
a little bit.
I have--
I have a lot of experience,
'cause when we did audionet,
which turned into broadcast.Com,
we started
the streaming business.
What happens is, R Dub creates
his show, "Slow jams,"
and he goes to radio stations,
when he says,
"Look, I'm gonna give you
this amazing content for free.
"what I'm gonna get in return
are radio commercials
that you'll run,
that I'll sell."
And he says, "Okay, I have
'x' number of listeners,
so my spot's worth
'x' number of dollars per Spot."
Then he goes out there
and tries to sell 'em.
(Kevin) it immediately leads
to this question--
if I take a map of America,
which Markets do you not have?
Well, there's 274
rated Markets.
We're in 62 Markets, so we've
barely tapped the potential.
Now I'm the investor. I got
my investor hat on, saying...
here we go.
There's tremendous
growth potential here.
Yeah.
But R Dub's been on
for 160 years.
Why doesn't he have
those Markets?
Because I am finally
ready to hire
my own in-House affiliate
sales director,
who--his entire job,
8, 12, 15 hours a day,
is to not only travel
But bang those phones
and spread the word about
"Sunday night slow jams."
So is that what you're
gonna do with the money?
Absolutely.
The opportunities
and the possibilities
are endless,
but that is the solution,
is hiring the one guy.
Do 19- And 20-year-Olds
really listen to slow jams?
Bruno Mars released a huge
number-One slow jam this year.
Rihanna, Usher, Frank ocean--
There's a huge resurgence.
And let me ask you this--
Have you ever been in love?
(Robert and Lori laugh)
Daymond?
Many times.
He's still paying for it.
(laughter)
do you remember the first
time you fell in love?
Do you remember that feeling
deep down inside,
those--Those butterflies?
That's what the show captures.
Last time I had those feelings,
my stock hit a hundred bucks
a share.
(laughter)
Let's not even discuss
the valuation.
You say you're worth $750,000.
Sure.
Let's leave that aside,
because we're in love
right now.
We are in love.
♪ We're in love ♪
Oh, sorry.
How do I get... (laughs)
♪ How do I get
my $75,000 back? ♪
(laughter)
We are about to explode,
and we are about to grow
faster than We've ever
grown before.
Even if we simply maintain,
for $75,000 you get
a 20% return on your money.
That's simple math.
(Lori) I love romantic Music,
but when I sit here and think
about you really expanding,
I'm not sure it's just this
sales manager that you need.
I feel like you need a hook.
You need something
really clever and unique
that draws people in.
I feel like there needs
to be more,
and so, for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you very much
for your time and for listening.
The radio Market
as an investment sucks.
I can tell you that
as an institutional investor.
This is radioactive waste
out there. It's terrible.
R Dub, thank you very much,
but I'll pass. I'm out.
You've been doing it
for 20 years,
and you're making
a good living,
and you're in 40%
of the potential Market?
That's the positive.
But I just don't think one sales
guy makes the entire business.
Because if that's the key
for you,
find a guy, give him some
percentage of your business,
and he will really hustle
for you out there.
Yeah.
That's the path that I see.
I don't see how you're gonna
build a business
with my $75,000. I'm out.
Look, you're in an industry
that, as you know,
is incredibly difficult.
Your Market is geared towards
a Younger audience,
and that Market does listen
more online,
does listen to their ipods
and use devices
to get their music.
I don't think you're doing
things in a way
that you could reach
the Younger audience,
the demographics
that you want to go to.
I think it's gonna make it
tough, if not impossible,
for any investor
to get their money back,
and for those reasons,
I'm out.
So looks like Daymond and I
will take off
and blow up the slow jam
industry by ourselves, but...
(laughter)
All right, good luck, guys.
I don't listen
to the type of radio
that you are producing,
and I just don't
understand it.
I have to be passionate about
the businesses I invest in.
I'm out.
All right. Hey, sharks,
thank you so much for your time.
Thank you, guys.
Thanks, Brian. Great job.
Thanks, Brian.
Long road home?
(laughs)
♪ Sunday night slow jams ♪
Brian, even the biggest
financial tycoon
can't stop music,
and they can't stop love.
(laughs) No.
♪♪
I'm Pete Hamborg.
This is my oldest son Gus.
I live with my wife
and five sons
in Sunny Huntington Beach,
California,
and we are the inventors
of hamboards.
We are the epitome of
a Southern California
beach family.
Me and my all my brothers
are all lifeguards,
my dad's a firefighter,
and we all surf.
♪♪
I've lived and surfed
in Huntington Beach
for over 35 years.
I realized that
that great surfing feeling
that I've been able
to enjoy
is something that
everyone wants to connect with.
That's why we created
our product.
♪♪
(wheels whooshing)
We have a product
that will allow people
all over the country
to truly experience
the feeling of surfing--
Without water.
Hamboards is growing.
Our orders are increasing,
and we really sense
the hamboards brand
is gaining traction.
We need an investment
from the sharks
because we simply don't have
enough money
to make the amount of boards
we need to meet the demand.
We would like to expand
hamboards
into the rest of America
so that everyone can enjoy
surfing,
even if it's on land.
♪♪
(surf music playing)
(Robert) whoa.
Oh, that is so cool.
Hi. I'm Pete Hamborg
from Hamboards.
I'm the founder.
This is Donnie. He's my cousin.
Hi.
This is Gus.
He's my oldest son.
How's it going?
We're asking for $100,000
for 15% of our company.
When skateboarding
was first invented,
the idea was to get
a piece of wood
to feel like surfing
when you rode it.
It's been the unattainable
holy grail of skateboard design.
Somebody has finally done it,
and it was us.
Let me tell you how we did it.
A few years back,
I had five little grommets
running around the house,
and I wanted to teach them
how to surf.
One of the things I wanted
to add to the process
of teaching them how to surf
was to make
a really large skateboard.
What I ended up making
was something
that really didn't work
that well.
Thank god, one night,
one of my little brothers
left the giant skateboard
out in the driveway,
and my mom backed over it
in the family wagon.
When we jumped on it,
we actually realized,
hey, this thing feels like
surfing for the first time.
And what she had done
when she had backed over it
was she had modified
the trucks
so that it turned better.
My dad figured out
a way to replicate that,
and we started making
boards for ourselves
and riding them
all over Huntington Beach.
People were freaking out.
People wanted to buy 'em.
And so the next thing you knew,
we had a little business
in our garage,
making these
giant skateboards.
But I didn't really know
the business dynamics.
You know, 'cause Gus
and his brothers,
they're all lifeguards.
I'm a fireman.
So we were kind of hitting
some rough waters.
So we shook the family tree,
and Donnie fell out...
(laughing)
And we hit the ground
running.
These guys are terrific
at product and promotions,
but the first time I had
a real business meeting,
we went through the "cost
to goods sold" Spreadsheet,
and about an hour in,
these guys needed
a yoga break
and a 20-Minute nap.
So fast-forward to today.
You know,
I'm the company hard-Ass,
and the bills get paid.
We're hitting
our monthly objectives
like a small business team
should.
And the thing is growing out
from under us.
What's your business
background, Donnie?
I have a business background
from working at Dupont
for ten years,
and then I've been
an entrepreneur
for about ten years.
I built
a sporting goods business.
I invented a technology
that made
inflated sports Balls
stay inflated
for an awful long time
that was called never flat.
Oh, those are
the Spalding balls that--
That's right.
Yeah, yeah, that the nba used.
That's right. That was it.
Very clever. Okay, so you got
some background in this.
Yeah.
You know
what you're doing.
So who wants to jump on one of
these things and try 'em out?
I wanna try it out.
(Gus) Come on. Get over here.
We gotta get you
a helmet.
All right.
Can I try one?
(Richard) Yeah, yeah.
(Gus) We got plenty.
For sure.
All right.
I have a really,
really big head.
(Richard) So the bigger ones
are easier to use
because of the...
they're a little more
stable.
What you wanna do--You wanna be
in the front half of the board
when you're trying it
for the first time.
(Gus) Yeah.
Up probably on the sticker.
And don't be afraid
to get yourself some speed.
Yeah. Yeah.
You're gonna be fine.
♪♪
(Pete) That's it. That's it.
(Mark) No way!
Oh, that is so cool.
Whoo!
(laughter)
Ta-Da!
Nice.
(laughter)
(Pete) there it is!
Hey--There you go.
(Mark) There he goes. Wow.
(Gus) man.
Thank you.
Tell us about the company.
What are the sales?
How long you been doing it?
Well, uh, so,
for the last 12 months,
our sales are $225,000.
For this calendar year,
our plan is to hit $350,000.
(Kevin) Don, you've been
in the sports business.
These sales are anemic.
Quarter of a million dollars
is peanuts.
Right.
And if this is gonna take off,
it's gotta get into
the millions.
That's right.
How do you get to $10 million
in this business?
So we just brought on
our first two reps
a month and a half ago.
So we're looking at getting
into the surf, skate,
action sports stores.
Have you made this
proprietary?
We have an intellectual
property portfolio
comprising design patents...
Yeah.
On all the models,
tradeMarks--
But based on the modification
of the wheel set?
We don't have a utility
patent on that modification, no.
(Lori) So do other people
then make
a surfboard with wheels?
You can find a product
that looks like that.
In fact, we had somebody
that bought one
from somebody else,
and they called us up
wanting to return it to us
because it didn't ride
like a hamboard
is supposed to ride.
Pete, tell us,
what do people buy?
Which size
is the best seller?
This is our--This is our most
popular board right here.
It's, uh, called
the bamboo classic.
So it's made out of
solid bamboo.
Uh, it retails for $595.
And then our next
most popular is--
How much does it--
Let's start there.
How much does it cost
to make that?
to make it?
One-Third of that.
So $200?
Roughly speaking.
Okay. And where--
Where do you make them?
Everything is assembled
and built in Huntington Beach.
Okay.
(Lori)
I think, very cool product.
Love family businesses.
But it seems to me
more of a niche product,
maybe more coastal
than heartland.
I think I can get you excited
for a bigger Market
if I can walk back here and pull
something else out of here.
Okay.
Sure.
(Robert) There's more?
There's more.
(Pete) Wait.
So...
hamboard Plus land paddle
equals freedom.
Oh!
Interesting.
(Pete) Check this out.
(Gus) So...
ah.
Oh, wow.
Cool.
Whoo!
And that is how you
commute to work?
Yes.
That's right.
(Lori) Very cool product.
Think you guys are great,
and Innovation's great.
I personally feel
it's maybe coastal,
more, in popularity,
and more of a niche Market,
and so for that reason...
Mm-hmm.
I'm out.
Thanks.
What's your core competency?
What's gonna make you
a great company?
Our honest hope is
that we get to start
with this terrific product
that really connects with people
that love the surf culture,
and then we get
to extend that--
see, But just saying that you
extend surf culture elsewhere
isn't big enough.
You've got to tell me
how you expand beyond that,
because you've got to get
to the point where you're
selling 10,000
or 20,000 or 30 th--
I mean,
with tower paddle boards--
they're
online Marketing gurus.
We went from doing
$40,000
to we'll do probably
$3 million this year.
I wasn't interested until you
brought the land paddles, right?
Right.
Because
now all of a sudden
there's stand-Up paddleboard
for water.
Now there's stand-Up
paddleboard for land.
Yeah.
Exactly.
I can get that,
but if you're telling me
this is all about
surfing culture...
well--
That's not gonna resonate
with a 13-year-old kid
on a lake outside of Dallas.
I'm out.
I'm not worried about
the culture issue as much,
because there is a very large
skateboard industry.
You can define it in hundreds
of millions of dollars.
You have to figure out how to
get some percentage share of it.
Mm-hmm.
Had you shown me
that you've found that model
and that you were starting
at $250,000 in sales
and you have a path
to $20 million,
and all you need
is my gasoline
in the form of dollars
to pour on it,
I made have made
an investment here today.
But you don't have that.
So I'm out.
I-I have a level of interest
in it.
I'm--I'm--I'm looking
at this as something
for us to go out and license,
and I--it would be a big gamble.
The objective is for me
to go out and help
and assist to license
this product immediately,
fast, and get it out there.
Are you making an offer?
Yes. $100,000 for 30%.
Peter, I don't see it
as a licensing thing today.
You are not selling
water paddleboards on land.
Mm-Mm.
You're selling
the California dream, baby.
Right. Yeah.
(Lori laughs)
♪♪
Three sharks are out.
Gus, Pete, and Donnie
have an offer from Daymond,
but it's for double the equity
they originally offered,
but now Robert
seems interested.
You are not selling
water paddleboards on land.
Mm-Mm.
You're selling
the California dream, baby.
Right. Yeah.
(Lori laughs)
There is gonna be
a percentage of your customer
that is the hard-core surfer...
Mm-hmm.
But the much bigger percentage
is gonna be old, chubby guys
like me
that want to be kids like Gus.
(Pete) right.
That's the big Market.
Mm-hmm.
But to do that,
you have to have a great brand.
Yes.
You cannot be more authentic
than a fireman
with Five lifeguard kids
in Huntington Beach.
Right.
I actually think
your valuation was fair.
Thank you.
But I think you're gonna
need more money.
Mm-hmm.
And I want to be a bigger
partner with you guys.
Mm-hmm.
You need some discipline
in this business,
and that's where I can
help you.
I'll give you $300,000
for one-Third.
You guys have two huge offers
from two huge sharks.
So my angle is to go and do
a lot of licenses
to build this up on
people's existing machines.
Robert is basically
"do it yourself."
You were gonna license
the boards, too, right?
I want to license the boards.
I want to license the clothing.
But they can still
do their own boards.
'cause you're gonna have
to have that core following
of, well, this was actually
made by the hamboard guys.
(Robert) I want to be
in this business.
$300,000, 33%.
Do we have a deal?
30? 30%?
30%.
Robert, we want to do
business with you.
All right!
Great job, guys!
Awesome.
Bad move.
Right on.
Nice job, guys.
Thanks, everyone.
See ya!
(Lori) Good luck, guys.
(laughter)
We just got three times
what we were asking for.
I am charged up.
I am super stoked.
That was a great deal.
Great deal.
I wonder if you overpaid
for that.
I think the valuation
was fair.
It's a little rich,
but I-I get it.
You'll find out.
♪♪
Last season, Nate Holzapfel
came to the Shark Tank
with his innovative company,
the mission belt...
it's like a giant zip-Tie
for your pants.
And scored a deal
with Daymond John.
Daymond, I'd be crazy to not
want a partner like you.
I accept 100%.
My man.
Let's see what he's up to now.
♪♪
When I went on "Shark Tank,"
I was so blown away
and so honored
when Daymond wanted to invest
in my company.
Hey, what's up, nate?
Hey, Daymond.
What's going on, man?
The best part about Daymond
is he is totally accessible
to me at all times.
It's like being on the same
team with Michael Jordan.
This is a great start,
but this is just the beginning.
Before "Shark Tank,"
we had only sold
$39,000 worth of product
in 3 months.
Our very first Night
after Airing,
we sold $180,000 worth.
And within a month, we became
a million-Dollar company.
Hey, guys,
we got some great news.
We just sold
our 50,000th belt.
(cheering)
We've projected $3 million
in sales in the next 6 months.
That'll put us at $5 million
since airing.
Thanks for calling
mission belt.
This is becca.
How can I help you?
When I pitched in the tank,
I was the only employee
of the mission belt co.,
and I was selling these
door-To-Door.
Now we have over 20 employees
and our own facility.
It's an amazing feeling
to create jobs
in your own community.
It's nice to be able
to create an environment
where people want to come
to work and have a lot of fun,
and can take care
of their families.
Okay, guys, buy a belt,
feed a family.
(claps hands)
Every time somebody
buys a belt,
we use it to help families
feed themselves.
Mission belts has always had
a mission--
To end world Hunger
by helping people
become self-Sufficient.
Rather than just giving
people food,
we give them the tools
and the money they need
to go out and get their own
farms going and feed themselves.
Thanks very much
for a great effort.
(applause)
going on "Shark Tank"
is the single best decision
I've made for my business.
It's taken a small
little product
that was run out of my apartment
and made it into
a multimillion-dollar company.
That's only in America.
Only on "Shark Tank."
(all) Thank you, "Shark Tank"!
whoo!
Whoo!
♪♪
Next up is an entrepreneur
Who started his business
in his college dorm room,
with a big vision
for the future.
♪♪
Hi, sharks.
My name is Garrett Gee,
and my company is scan.
I'm here seeking an investment
of $1 million
for 5% of my company.
Now, sharks, before you
grill me with your questions,
I have a question for you.
How often
in your day-To-Day lives
do you see one of these
scannable codes?
They're everywhere.
At scan, we developed
a mobile app
which is the easiest way
to scan and interact
with any of these codes.
Let me show you how.
So first I'm going to scan
the barcode
from this camera's packaging.
It's as easy as...
(beep)
and that quickly, my app
just did a price check
showing me
how I can save $25.
Next, I'm going to scan
the Q.R. Code
from the tag
of this mission belt.
Daymond, have you heard
of this company before?
(laughing)
Yes. Mission belt.
Great company.
Then you're going
to love this.
(beep)
They, using our Web site,
created their own
custom Code
that can Link
to their Web site,
their youtube channel
for a video.
Do you want somebody
to actually be able
to purchase a product?
Or, as you see here,
their twitter.
So in one tap, that easily,
I just followed them on twitter.
How cool is that?
This all started
just two years ago.
Together with
two of my classmates,
we set out on a mission
to connect the real world
with the digital universe.
We are still young
and foolish enough
to believe that we can
change the world
from our college
dorm room.
So, sharks, which of you
is still young and foolish
enough to take a chance on us?
Garrett, what do you have today?
What's built?
We have our mobile app,
which is available
in the app store,
iphone, ipad, ipod,
android devices,
and windows.
Is it free?
When we started,
we were focusing on growing
our user base,
and so we started
with a free app,
kept it very simple.
It grew like crazy,
and over time,
as the company has grown,
we've started to introduce
better features
that users can pay for.
What's the most common
application
that the enterprises,
the businesses,
are doing on the site
with the application?
A lot of people are going
for the simple choices
to begin with.
They're saying,
"Here's our Q.R. Code,
"and it links
to our facebook page
so you can 'like' us,"
or "It links to our instagram."
Very easy stuff.
I create a Q.R. Code
that links to the actual
product and its price.
So now I don't just
scan this belt
and get more information,
I can scan this belt
and purchase it in one tap.
How many active users
does it have?
Actually, let me check.
I don't want
to tell you wrong.
All right, so here is
a live ticker
Showing people downloading
our app.
We get about a little more
than one a second.
51 million downloads?
That doesn't say anything.
How many scans
do you have a day?
I can tell you that last month,
there were 27 million people
who took out our app
and scanned it.
do you have any competition
for this?
This wasn't, like,
the newest, best idea.
But when I looked
at the other competition,
I didn't see anybody
executing on it
how I felt it needed
to be executed.
Garrett, what does it
do better?
One mistake that a lot
of our competition have made
is they kind of built
half of the table.
They didn't build the full
360 experience like we did.
Because people can go
to our Web site
and create codes,
and people can use
our own app,
we're the entire space.
How do you make money
with this?
That's why I'm here.
We're just now starting
to focus more and more
on monetization.
The plan is to keep a lot of
the user side of Things
completely free.
And then, for businesses,
they can come,
choose what type of Code
they want to create,
pay a monthly fee
to host that code
and keep it live
and Working, and--
has there been monetization
up until this point?
Not on the live Web site.
If you went
to our Web site right now,
you would not see, uh...
have you made any money today?
So we've made about
$30,000 a month
for the last few months
by reaching out
to a few
of our big companies
that have already been using
our product and then say,
"We want to choose you
as a beta customer"...
and they're paying you
for the beta?
Correct.
Are-aren't you concerned
that Q.R. Codes
are becoming dodo birds?
What's the future?
Because, I mean,
I can make an argument
that Q.R. Codes are gone.
Can I show you?
Yeah, absolutely.
I'm gonna show you
something special
we've been working on.
So I received a package
just the other day from google.
So this is google glass.
Okay, glass, scan this
Q.R. Code.
That easily I can interact
with the digital world.
So that's it?
That's what you did there?
Like, all you showed me there--
as--as a tech guy--
Was just another
hardware platform.
But google sent this to you
to do what?
To start implementing
our scanning technology
on both the business side
and the user side
into their hardware.
Not impressed.
I'm impressed by
the 51 million downloads
and your users--
That's great, right?
But you're not telling me
you're doing anything unique.
You've got a platform,
google goggles.
They have
a developers' program.
There's gonna be other people
doing scannables.
You haven't said what it is
that you're doing
that differentiates you
from any of the many.
You know, are you doing
something better with software?
Are you better integration
with third parties?
Is your a.P.I. Easier?
The things
you were talking about--
like, our a.P.I.
Was easier to work with,
the scan was just
that much faster.
(snaps fingers)
the design was just that much
more simple and beautiful.
It was very small things
that people don't think
they care about,
so when we went out
against a huge competition,
we were able
to rise to the top.
How much money has been
invested in your company
over the last two years?
When we were six months
into the business,
we had already passed
one million downloads.
We started to hear
from investors.
To be honest, I didn't know
a lot about investors.
And where did I learn
so much of the stuff initially?
From "Shark Tank."
And when google ventures
wanted to meet with us,
I was, like,
in "Shark Tank" Mode,
and I said, "I'm looking
for this much money,
and I want this,
deal or no deal."
And they looked at me and said,
"That's not how this works."
But I learned
from that experience,
and I kept going at it,
so total, we've raised
$8.7 million.
(Daymond)
8.7 raised already.
Why are you exactly here?
Is it just for exposure?
No. Definitely not.
Every time we've
involved somebody,
we give somebody
this much of the business,
and they deliver us
this much value.
I believe the carpet is there
for those who desperately
need help,
the banks turned them down,
they've lost a lot,
or they--they don't have
any hope.
I don't think you need
the money. I'm out.
I think you are amazing.
You obviously are brilliant.
But I am not the best person
sitting here
to help you
in this technical Arena.
So for that reason,
I'm going out.
It hurts every time.
(chuckles)
Garrett, I gotta tell you,
we've never had somebody
ask for a million dollars
in flip-flops.
Oh.
So--but that's cool.
(laughs)
Um... look,
there's no doubting
the downloads.
Unbelievably impressive.
But there's nothing
proprietary,
and I worry about
the competition as it grows.
For that reason, I'm out.
Your valuation is $20 million
for a business that actually
doesn't have yet
a business model
that is recurring.
So the leap of faith
for any shark
is just risk tolerance,
I think. That's it.
I can't make that leap of faith.
Show me the money,
not the downloads.
I'm out.
I've notice a pattern.
As I've been meeting
with investors,
there have been those
that look at me,
and those who look
at my numbers.
There's investors that think
there's a perfect recipe
to success every time.
I don't believe in that.
I believe, to do something
truly amazing,
there's got to be
a little bit of crazy,
a little bit of foolish.
You're--You're giving me
a lot of visions,
but you're not giving me
a lot of realities.
I'm a big fan
of the sensor business.
I think that's the future
of technology.
The fundamental problem
that I have is
scans versus sensors.
In a sensor-Driven world,
the information
is accumulated and gathered
everywhere
with No action by the user,
whereas in your world,
whether it's google glasses
where you have to talk,
whether you have to take
your phone and scan,
in a sensor-Driven world,
these don't exist.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you very much
for all of your time.
Very impressive, Garrett.
Yes, very impressive.
Very impressive.
Great job.
Good luck.
Thank you.
Thanks, Garrett.
Look what "Shark Tank"
Is producing--
Kids like that.
Amazing, right?
Yes, very impressive.
Amazing.
I'm scared.
Brilliant guy.
(Daymond) I'm very, very proud.
Now... I want a royalty.
(laughs)
(Garrett)
Investing in our company,
and especially in us young guys
that are running this company
is definitely
a big leap of faith.
But that's the part
I like about it.
That's the beauty
of entrepreneurship at its best.
♪♪
Next into the tank
is the Hooks family
with a business
made in their garage.
♪♪
Hi. I'm Lily...
I'm Emma...
and I'm Brian.
Sharks, we're seeking
a $30,000 investment
for a 25% stake
in our company...
(all) Screenmend.
"What's Screenmend?",
you ask?
It's the easiest way
to patch A screen ever.
Screenmend was invented
about three years ago.
When my mom made us
clean out the porch.
I was trying to patch
a hole in the porch screen
with a self-Adhesive patch,
but it wasn't working.
He just kept trying
to press the patch on,
and it kept falling off.
Lily was trying to scrape
some melted wax off the table.
I hate that job.
Well, when our dad
complained about
how the patch wouldn't stick,
Lily said...
"Hey, brain"--
our nickname for our dad--
"Why don't you put wax
on that patch?"
We realized Lily might be
on to something,
so we tried creating
a screen patch soaked in wax.
And it worked.
When the first patch
stayed on for over a year,
we realized that we had
created a simple
and Marketable solution
to a common household problem.
Thanks, Emma.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Lily is now
going to show you
the fastest and easiest way
to patch a screen.
You've got it, brain.
(laughter)
"Brain."
Simply cut the patch to size
and apply with heat
from a hair Dryer
for 30 to 60 seconds.
(whirring)
now that's on the hottest
temperature, right?
Yes.
Yes, it is.
(hair Dryer turns off)
and you're done.
Screenmend is fast, easy,
and extremely effective.
Sharks, we built this business
from the ground up,
and now we need your help.
I want to grow my business
so I can sit where you are
one day.
(laughs)
So who wants to make a deal
and help us mend screens
all across America?
Sometimes
the simplest products
make the best products,
because...
Yeah, it really,
really helped us,
because we had, um,
we had a Bunny...
(laughs)
And she would just
eat through the screens.
This is Bunny-Proof?
Yeah.
(laughter)
Lily, do you mind asking
how old you are?
I'm 12.
I'm 15.
How many of these
have you sold?
750.
750 units?
Yes.
Brian, what do you
sell them for?
$6.95.
What does it cost you
to make it?
31 cents.
(Lori) Wow.
Nice. Good job.
That's a nice margin.
You need bigger margins.
Where are you manufacturing?
We've expanded from
the kitchen to the garage.
(laughs)
Who makes the packaging?
You guys make it all, and--
Yes. The packaging
is 53 cents,
and the materials
are 31 cents.
How many competitors
are out there?
There's at least three
or four competitors.
They're nothing like us,
though.
(laughs) You tell 'em.
They--they just--
Ours are better.
Why are you better, Lily?
Yeah, why are you better?
Why are you better?
Well, because ours
stays on for longer,
and it's quicker,
and the other patches
use, like, tape and stuff.
(Emma) some of them
don't stick on Well,
and then the others, once it's
exposed to the elements--
Dust, wind, rain, etcetera--
The backing wears off,
and it falls off.
And yours does not
fall off in rain?
Nope.
What stops your competitor
from just doing
the wax gig you're doing?
Well, we do have
a provisional patent.
So you think that'll survive?
It'll actually clear?
Well, we hope to grow
to be able to afford
a utility patent.
Did you do any type
of patentability search
to see if there's any prior
out--out there
that would preclude you
from getting a patent?
Uh, I have not.
Um, we have invested
all the capital, um,
from the business
back into the business,
and that's why we're here.
Lily, why do you need
the $30,000?
Um, we would like to grow
our packaging,
because we had, um, interest
from BED bath & beyond
and home depot,
but they said they couldn't put
our products in their store
because of the packaging.
The packaging needed work.
So...
why?
Because they can't hang it
on, like, clips or anything.
Clip strip.
And we really didn't know
where to go from there.
So the problem is getting this
into retail,
which requires
a packaging redesign.
Exactly.
Yes.
And that's what we need
help with.
I think you guys have
come up with something great,
and I want to do this deal,
but I more want to do it
from the standpoint
that I'm a dad like you,
you know?
And you have two great girls.
The challenge is
it's just a lot of work.
You know, if I give you
the money
and you can go off
and make it happen,
that's fine, but you need
the knowledge--
the packaging, the back office--
All that stuff,
and I wouldn't have the time
to help you with that.
I'm out.
I understand. Thank you
for your consideration.
Thank you.
This business is too small
for me to invest in.
It's tugging
at my heartstrings,
and I never let that
influence me as a an investor.
I'm--I'm profoundly, uh,
supportive
of what you're trying to do.
But to build this business up
is going to be
a fair amount of work,
and I don't want to go on that
journey with you, unfortunately.
I'm out.
All right.
Thank you.
(Robert) Brian, let me tell you
where I'm at.
You guys have done
a great job with this.
You're going to be successful,
but I don't see how I can
invest today
To help grow my money.
I'm out.
(Mark) Look, guys,
tell you a quick story.
When I was 16,
started collecting stamps.
I went to a stamp show,
bought a stamp for 50 cents.
I took that stamp into
another stamp dealer.
It turns out
it was a $50 stamp.
Boom. I made $49.50
just like that.
And I started growing
my little business,
and my dad would take me
to stamp shows.
He had no idea
what was going on.
But he introduced me
to somebody
who gave me
a few thousand dollars.
I grew that business
and grew that business,
paid his money back,
and I'll be forever
grateful to him.
I'm not gonna let you guys
not get a deal.
It's not about the money.
I'll give you guys $30,000
for 25%.
I'm not here to tell you
I'm--I'm an expert
in any of this.
I have no clue.
But I know how to find
people that do.
Somebody stood up for me.
I'll stand up for you guys.
Do you want to do a deal?
(inhales) We would...
(exhales)
Wait a minute.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
♪♪
Three sharks are out.
Seeing himself
in the young entrepreneurs,
Mark has offered
the Hooks family
exactly what they asked for.
I'm not gonna let you guys
not get a deal.
It's not about the money.
I'll give you guys $30,000
for 25%.
Somebody stood up for me.
I'll stand up for you guys.
Do you want to do a deal?
We would...
(exhales)
Wait a minute.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
I love what you did.
Your ages--Amazing.
To create something
that it appears
that no one else has been
able to do as well--
We're talking major corporations
with millions of dollars.
I feel the way
to really benefit you
would be for me to take over
the manufacturing,
to get you into
bed bath & beyond
with the right packaging,
and then to give you
tv presence.
So, Mark, I'd like to offer you
to go in with me,
but because I know how much
work and effort
it's going to take,
because we're really starting
from ground up,
so I would want 50%
of the company,
and the same $30,000.
I'm not gonna negotiate
with them.
No?
It's just a good deal
as it is.
It's okay. But my offer
would be 50/50
for the $30,000.
You've got an offer
from Mark--$30,000 for 25%.
Twice as much equity from Lori
for $30,000,
but she wants 50%.
What are you gonna do?
(Robert) Do you need
to talk about it?
I think we'd like to.
I think--Yeah.
Yes.
Go ahead.
Really smart little girls.
Mark is being
very generous...
yes.
But Lori is willing to go
the extra yard...
really.
To put this out there.
I think there is
a lot of work here.
I think there's
a tremendous amount of work.
I-I don't think...
(Daymond) No, there's
a lot of work.
Lori's wrong
in what she's doing.
No, Lori's absolutely right.
Let's summarize
where we're at,
'cause this is
a reMarkable turnaround here.
Got two offers.
Mark is willing to give you
what you asked for--
$30,000 for 25%.
Lori wants more because she
feels she has to do more work--
50% for the same amount
of money.
What do you want to do?
♪♪
Lori, we accept your offer.
(Daymond) All right, Good.
Good.
Congratulations.
And thank you so much, Mark.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
No problem at all.
(laughing)
Thank you so much.
You're very clever
young women.
Good luck, guys.
(Emma) Thank you.
(Mark laughs)
(Kevin) whoa!
Oh, nice.
Let me try that.
Lori, I have a very big house.
You're coming to my house
to fix all my screens
right now.
(laughs)
Oh...
Oh, my God.
(laughs)
(Lily) It's really exciting
working with Lori
because, um, I know Lori
can get our product
into stores and on, like,
tv shows,
and that just would really
help us out.